The release of the Epstein files has
sparked widespread scrutiny online with
many [music] viewers re-examining music
videos through a more critical lens.
Some are asking whether major artists
like Lady Gaga, [music] Justin Bieber,
and Katy Perry might just be alluding to
a deeper hidden layer within the [music]
industry. But the real question is, are
these supposed overlaps with the Epstein
[music] files just a coincidence, or is
there something intentionally hiding in
plain [music] sight? Or This episode may
contain content that is not suitable for
children. Viewer discretion is advised.
All right, everybody, we're out of
retirement for LED Live. What do you
feel about that?
>> short-lived, wasn't it?
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> So, we're not back back. It's not the
the original goodbye LED Live was not an
April Fools' joke, even though it's not
even April Fools' yet. We're actually we
were actually quitting our weekly
episodes, but we always said in that
announcement that we'll come and do a a
podcast-style format
once in a while when something pops up,
and this just this has popped up, so
here we are. But uh yeah, it will still
we're still working on our other
longer-format documentaries as well. So,
check out Patreon if you want to know
more about what we're working on. In
light of the um Epstein files that have
come out, there's some very disturbing
things that we have seen over the last
couple years, but probably had no real
context to it, might have dismissed it.
Okay, and you're sharing all this in
light of the Epstein files.
>> In light of the Epstein files, because
now what's come out and they've
basically said um this is what we've
seen happen. I mean, there's some crazy
stories that have come out of this. I
mean, in the Epstein files, they say
they're eating babies. So, the main
document with the new Epstein files
where cannibalism is shown is this one
that I could find.
>> Looks like an email.
Yes. So, this is some email
communication between uh an NYPD
detective. He was from the Bureau
Child Exploitation and Human Trafficking
Task Force, and he talked to or he
communicated with a special agent from
the FBI New York office. So, they
basically discuss a a victim who came up
to them and was like, "Hey, uh this I
witnessed some cannibalism, and there
were some US presidents involved. He was
on a boat."
Uh we're not going to show it because
you can look it up if you want to. It's
just a little dark. We don't want to
show it on a screen, but uh it's out
there.
And uh yeah, but authorities ended up
dropping the case. That's what happened.
>> Okay. So. Yeah. Well, it's also
interesting that the fact-checking
website Snopes had noticed that after
they had reported on this file in the
Epstein files,
um
that one
particular about this supposed
cannibalism where US presidents were
present and got removed.
>> According to this person. Yeah. Later
on, a more formal summary of the event
got posted.
>> Yeah.
And that is this one right here. This
has got posted. And now the earlier
file's been put back again as well, so
you can search up both if you want. And
there's file names for those. They're
EFTA00147661
and EFTA012
46048.
Yeah. I also noticed on the Snopes
website, this fact-checking website,
that they actually reached out to the
FBI and asked them like, "Hey, why did
you not further investigate this case
from this supposed victim?"
And they just said they don't have any
further comment. So, take it for what
you want with that, but that's we we're
going to share the facts, and that's how
the idea of cannibalism is actually in
the Epstein files.
Um yeah.
It's in there.
>> Okay. Honestly, this is alarming.
Let's check this out. Let's look at look
at a couple of these. There was a
a music video
that was put out by Katy Perry, and uh
it was called Bon Appétit. Have you seen
this one? No. Okay, so it's kind of just
a very disturbing um obviously we can
barely show any of this because
>> riding with? It's a cake, okay?
>> Oh, it's a cake. Okay. Okay. piping of a
cake, and what they're doing is they're
kneading her like dough,
um and they're basically going to turn
her into a piece of meat or food, okay?
And
So, this is like one of those things
that you see it, you dismiss it as like,
"Okay, this is just weird, strange, and
what in the world?" Like they put her in
a um
boiling pot, they boil her, they put
food around her, and then the rest of
the music video is all about these
celebrities that are eating her, and now
she's even re-emerged, and she's now
eating somebody else. I am being served
as a meal. It was pretty fun, but the
concept of the video is basically they
think they're going to eat me
cuz they've been prepping me this whole
time, but the reality is I turn it on
them. It's a trap. I'm going to eat
them. Eat it up. All you can eat. Katy
Perry way.
Hey, going to make you hungry every time
you watch the video. You're looking at
the culture. You dig what we're saying.
Can you say my stomach is growling right
now? What in the world did we just
watch?
>> bizarre. So, I don't I I I don't like,
you know,
when you see things like this, you're
just like, "Okay, they're music industry
people. They're weird."
And but I mean, think about that. I I if
this isn't real, I don't know what's
more disturbing. That somebody would
actually make a music video with these
kind of elements in it. I was reading
some of the comments on the Bon Appétit
music video, and somebody pointed out
that the people wanting to eat Katy
Perry are also dressed up looking
wealthy and powerful, kind of like the
industry elites. Have you seen any of
this stuff, Alicia? I have not seen this
video.
Yeah, it's a bit like, why would you do
that? Why would you eat eat people and
and even pretend that you're going to do
that?
>> a video about that is so strange. Yeah.
But it gets it gets worse and worse,
okay? So, that's that video. So, this
here is Justin Bieber's music video.
>> I Is this the one where he sings yummy
the yummy yum, you're my yummy yum?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> I always thought he would sing this
about his wife. Okay.
>> the yummy yum. So, he posted on his
Instagram a bunch of pictures of babies.
Yes. Yes.
You showed us that.
>> And said yummy.
What Like
like that's just a very strange thing to
say.
And then there's a picture of him
underneath the cake, if you notice.
>> was a child.
>> And it said yummy.
Like whatever he's trying to put out
there like creatively is strange. Yeah.
So, if you look at one of the comments
in this YouTube video, you'll see that
this person points out that all the
people that are eating and partying,
they're all dressed up like adults at a
fancy party.
Just like um Katy Perry's video,
uh but the entertainers, you'll notice
they're all children. That's
interesting. Yeah. I mean, it's an
interesting observation. Again, I don't
want to I don't want to stretch it
farther than it should, but it's an
interesting observation. Yeah. Mhm. I
think
the thing is, even if none of it has any
connection, it's disturbing that
Hollywood and the music industry puts
out that kind of imagery. Yeah. Yeah,
good point. That's really kind of the
bottom line. It's that's a good point.
Like what are children supposed to do at
a party where a bunch of adults are
eating and drinking and having fun, and
they're the entertainers. It's off. They
are minors. Yeah. Now I'm super
disturbed about that. And Justin, when
he was interviewed by this and he was
talking about the struggles that he had
in the music industry, listen to what he
says. Did you feel protective
of her? Yeah, I definitely feel
protective of her. Um it was hard for me
being that young and being in the
industry and not knowing where to turn.
I just want to protect her, you know?
I don't [snorts] want her to go through
anything I went through. I don't wish
that upon anybody. You know, we're not
sure if Justin Bieber had witnessed any
weird stuff when he was younger. Like we
don't know.
What we do know is that he he struggles
with depression a lot. He struggles with
anxiety a lot, and he says it's because
he's been through a bunch of stuff in
the music industry. What the end
entails, we don't know. Um could it be
that he's seen some weird exploitative
things? Yeah, possible, you know, if
looking at what's happening in bigger
sphere of the world of the elites. So,
check this out, y'all. Justin, he's in
You ever seen the movie 48 Hours? Right
now, he's having 48 hours with Diddy,
him and his boy. Um
They're having the times of their lives.
Like like like the you know, where we
hanging out and what we doing. Um we we
can't really disclose,
but um it's definitely a 15-year-old's
dream. I don't really I don't have legal
guardianship of him, but for the next 48
hours,
he's with me. So, um
and yeah, and we going to go full buck
full crazy. Going crazy. Crazy. I'm
taking this out tonight.
>> What you want to do? What you want to do
over the next 48 hours? 48 hours, let's
go um are we going to let's just go get
some girls. Let's go hang out with some
girls.
A man after my heart. That's what I'm
talking about here.
Well, you know, Bieber did share a
public statement where he said he was
not one of Diddy's victims.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um you know, you never know.
Is that
is he trying to protect somebody? Is he
under some kind of, you know, industry
gag order?
We don't know that. We don't know any of
that kind of stuff, but um at least, you
know, I guess you just
you kind of take people at face value,
and he said he wasn't one of the
victims, and
I don't know. That's all you can do.
Hopefully he wasn't, and he's not
covering it up. There you go. I can't
create some conspiracy about something
did happen, but it's highly suspicious.
And I think the same happened with I
think it was Ne-Yo as well. Like why
would you ever do that? I moved to New
York City.
And I lived with Sean Puffy Combs for a
year. It was curious. I got a chance to
see some things. It was it was pretty
wild.
>> Usher's past comments on Diddy now going
viral. These are places that a
13-year-old probably should not be.
>> We're sending you over to something
called Puffy Flavor Camp. In the '90s,
do you understand what that's like? I
went there to see the lifestyle. Right.
And I saw it. It was It was pretty wild.
There were very curious things taking
place. Uh-huh.
>> And I didn't necessarily understand.
Biggie Smalls was there.
>> was there, Lil' Kim, Craig Mack, you
know, all
>> people are hanging around. Yeah, man.
Faith Evans,
Jodeci, Mary J. Gosh, they didn't know
nothing about this. Oh.
>> [laughter]
>> I was having a good time, you know what
I mean? Did she have you doing any
chores? Are you doing dishes at all? I
mean, did they keep you humble somewhat?
Or are you just like, can you stay up
till 4:00 in the morning with them and
party? I mean, I could. I actually
stayed up longer than them. I hear the
party with you. I don't want to go to
the clubs. I'm Matter of fact, I'm too
young to even be in here. Why you got me
in clubs? There were
There were a lot of things I seen.
>> [music]
>> And a lot of positions that I think I
was put in where I had to make very,
very tough decisions.
>> have money? What's going on? I mean, I
had like per diem. Oh. I had like, you
know, like a living. Yeah, it's pretty
crazy. You're a dad now. Would you ever
send your kid to Puffy Camp? Hell no.
So, what inspired this conversation
right here is Taylor Alessia has a
channel. She does a lot of similar work
to us.
>> She's shouted out us out a couple times.
Thanks, Taylor. You
guys should check out her channel. She's
got some some really cool videos Listen
to what she says about Billie Eilish.
So, now Justin Justin Bieber wants to
protect her. Her song bury a friend is
really interesting to listen to now
being a Christian and also with
everything coming out. It really makes
you look at the lyrics very differently.
Today I'm thinking about the things that
are deadly. The way I'm drinking you
down like I want to drown, like I want
to end me. Bury a friend, try to wake
up. Hannibal class, killing the sun.
It's probably something that shouldn't
be said out loud. Honestly, I thought
that I would be dead by now. The debt I
owe, got to sell my soul cuz I can't say
no. No, I can't say no. Then my limbs
all froze and my eyes won't close. Bury
a friend, try to wake up. Hannibal
class, [music] killing the sun. I don't
know why you would want to sing that.
I don't know why anybody'd want to sing
that. Yeah, what do you mean by Hannibal
class? I mean, cannibalism is not
something that we
talk about ever.
Yeah. I'm starting to feel like, why are
these guys all making videos about
eating people? There are some very
strange things that are going on and
>> Oh, Kesha, too? Kesha wrote a song about
being a cannibal. Who Why are all these
artists that are very well known talking
about this? Yeah. I I think it's such a
strange thing to talk about. So, listen
to what she says about Kesha. These are
She's going to read Kesha's lyrics, so
check this out. Moving on to a song that
a lot of people are talking about amidst
these files. If you look at the newest
comments underneath this video, which is
crazy because this song came out years
ago, but the song is by Kesha and it is
called cannibal. Take a listen to this.
I eat boys up breakfast and lunch. Then
when I'm thirsty, I drink their blood.
Carnivore, animal, I am a cannibal.
[music] I eat boys up, you better run.
Your little heart goes pitter-patter. I
want your liver on a platter. Use your
finger to stir [music] my tea and for
dessert, I'll suck your teeth. Be too
sweet and you'll be a goner. I'll pull a
Jeffrey Dahmer. [music]
Like so many others, Kesha is no
stranger to using occult symbolism in
her music videos. They show you who they
walk with and who is operating in their
music. I'm once again, man, why is
somebody else is writing a song about
eating people and drinking their blood?
>> You know, it used to be kind of fringe.
Like like it was for artists who were
Oh, what's his name?
Uh Marilyn Manson. Like he Like those
kind of people would be drinking animal
blood and have a heart on stage. And
that was like, oh yeah, but you were
like that kind of guy. And now it's like
I mean
The It's more and more acceptable. Katy
Perry is a pretty widely accepted artist
from the teens to whatever. She's not
looked at the like super, super, super
dark. And you can hear her music walking
through Walmart. Justin Bieber. I mean,
you I think there's so much going on
here that the Epstein files have really
brought to our attention. And it's like
everything that people would pass off as
conspiracy theory is now starting to
really just like be like, wow, this
world is dark and we need Jesus. Mhm.
You know? Okay. There's another one that
made a music video. Now, in the very
beginning of the music video, this is
what you see in the very, very
beginning. She's is black and white. She
looks like she's really this dark
figure. She has something wet all over
her, but you cannot see what it is, but
obviously she's painted herself with
something where only you see her whites
of her eyes.
>> Oh, the all-seeing eye. Let's take out
one eye. And once again, please forgive
me for the scantily dressed. We will
have to like blur her out. But what do
you see right here in the music video?
Looks kind of like a demon.
A woman riding a beast. Right. Oh. A
beast. Eyeballs hanging out of this guy.
I mean, there is no secret of what these
music industry artists are into.
>> a woman wearing red.
>> She's a woman. She's become a priestess.
She's friends with the Grim Reaper
and falling in love with the Grim
Reaper.
And it's just like strange
blood. What is going on with these
people and why are we as a society okay
with this?
I I think, you know,
there is a really good reason why we
should probably be careful with the
music, right? And
did you guys hear about in the news?
Neil Patrick Harris apologizes for
mocking Amy Winehouse after her death.
He made a cake with her dead at the
birthday party and then the whole
birthday party began to eat it. OH,
WHAT?
WHAT? I am disturbed at at the idea that
people would even think this is
And look at what it says on the thing.
The corpse of Amy Winehouse. And who
makes that cake? Well, some celebrity
baker that is all in on it. Who would do
that? Like that's
You know, they have They're running
different circles up there.
>> Why?
I mean, why is the question that I have
other than this world is evil? So, I I
don't know if you guys have noticed this
or not, but um
a lot of people online have been
connecting that infamous Amy Winehouse
corpse cake from Neil Patrick Harris's
party to this image of Lady Gaga
assuming that she's also eating a corpse
cake, but that's actually not correct.
>> Um it was at a benefit party for the
Watermill Center in New York, which is
like an arts center.
And the party was titled Devil's Heaven.
It's messed up. Yeah. It's pretty It's
pretty dark. And so, they had some
really
dark kind of like It's called I think
it's called live art. Like humans who
make up the art.
>> Yeah. Yes, according to the Hamptons Art
Hub, this was an installation called
Funeral de Miel. Mhm. And it's French
for honey funeral. What? Which is So
crazy.
>> I know. The whole thing just weirds me
out.
Anyway, it's a real woman who's laying
there and she has honey all over which
is supposed to resemble, you know, a
corpse in a coffin. It's supposed to be
like
I don't know. Is she supposed to be
bleeding or something? I Yeah, well, I
guess she's bleeding. I guess well, I
guess maybe she
It's all just weird. Yeah, so Lady Gaga
is sitting there with a spoon
and just eating up the honey which is
supposed to resemble blood next to a
corpse. So, it's still really dark. It's
still really dark. Just disturbing.
Yeah. Either way, she's standing there
with
What's that lady's name? Abramović.
Yeah. That's the one that does the
spirit cooking. And she throws the blood
all over the walls and all that kind of
stuff.
Listen to what the Bible says in Hebrews
9:22 about blood. Indeed, under the law,
almost everything is purified with blood
and without the shedding of blood, there
is no forgiveness of sins.
What do you think about that? It comes
from
It's quoting Leviticus and it's the way
God set up the system, you know.
Something had to die to pay
for sin. But it's only God. Yeah. Like
he's not talking about sacrificing other
people or innocent babies or anything
like that. He's talking about he he put
himself out there. Jesus put himself out
there and did it for the rest of
humanity. And I think that what's
happening here is the absolute opposite.
Instead of giving life, that's why God
did that. Jesus did that so that we
could have an opportunity to live life.
We are condemned to die.
And all of a sudden, it's like Jesus is
saying, no, no, no, let me take that
penalty for you. And that shedding of
blood is what saves us.
And here they're making a mockery of the
blood and eating it. And instead of like
giving your life to save the baby, to
take an innocent child, it's like how
satanic could you possibly get? Well,
and also in the Old Testament,
obviously, there was the sacrificing of
animals, but this was merely set up as a
way to point people to the Messiah.
Right? Like especially when cuz
sometimes also a lamb was specifically
sacrificed as a sin offering. It was
pros to teach the old the Israelites and
and the Jewish people like, hey, Jesus
is going to come. He's going to fulfill
the the type and Jesus is the antitype.
He's going to fulfill that as the one
who's going to be sacrificed for you and
and So, that was a beautiful thing. And
in fact, a couple months ago, we had a
little lamb in the office because we
were shooting a scene of I think it was
Cain and Abel, right? Like the fruit
versus the lamb.
And and so, I remember just holding it.
It it this cute little thing and I I kid
you not, I almost teared up that day
because I realized
this thing is innocent and it's it feels
so wrong for this innocent cute gentle
little thing to it's so docile to have
to die because I messed up. But then I
was like, well, that's what Jesus did
for me and that's what this was all
about.
>> And you as the sinner had to do that.
Yeah. You were the one that would lay
your hands on it and seeing this thing
that is is vulnerable to your care
and you have to be the one that that
that's takes its life.
>> Yeah.
You know, it's interesting the Bible
says that the life is in the blood. Yep.
And
you know, if you look at blood from a
biological perspective, the thing that's
in that your blood carries is oxygen,
right? It carries it all throughout your
body. Without oxygen, you can't breathe,
right?
So, when you think about this from this
perspective of, you know,
man and God and and you have life inside
of you. Look at what happened in the
Garden of Eden. Man was there, a full
body was formed
and there was a state at which he's
fully formed, everything is is there,
but there's no life. Mhm.
Right?
Life happened when
the breath was put into his nostrils.
>> Right. Right? And God's breath goes in
and now you have like that first
injection of oxygen into his system,
right? And the life is in the blood. So,
I'm not I'm not trying to make blood
like mystical or anything like that.
It's just kind of a very interesting
thing to think about. I think God was
the one that originally put that in
there and so there's there's something
sacred about it. And so whether you have
people that are out there doing these
horrible heinous things, you know, or
they're making a joke about it, it's all
a mockery
against what God did because he's the
one that also says later, eat my flesh,
drink my blood. Mhm. You know.
>> But it was symbolic.
>> It was symbolic. And this is the
counterfeit of that. It's like almost
like the devil said, oh yeah, that's
what you do to get saved, then I'm going
to give you the absolute opposite of
that.
>> Yeah, God does not endorse cannibalism.
He wasn't saying like, come and eat me.
He was saying, partake of Jesus through
through the word, have a relationship
with him, right? Like his body is is the
the bread that was broken, it's the word
of God and and so you understand Jesus
and come to him. That's what he was
trying to say with that. Yeah.
First Peter 1:18-19.
Knowing that you were ransomed from the
futile ways inherited from your
forefathers,
not with perishable things such as
silver or gold, but with the precious
blood of Christ, like that of a lamb
without blemish or spot. Which speaks to
your point about the innocence of the
lamb. I think just having that lamb in
the office for the short amount of time
that we did, that really helped me
visualize like like this gift that God
gave us.
>> Yeah.
It was pretty amazing. For this is my
blood of the covenant, which is poured
out for many for the forgiveness of the
sins. So, what is the blood doing?
It's allowing you to be forgiven. It's
allowing you to be forgiven and there's
power in the blood. That's why we sing
that song.
Yeah, like you're saying, there is power
in Christ's blood and I think that
that's why it's even more sad to see
these celebrities promoting this kind of
counterfeit of that with all of this
weird cannibalism stuff.
And you know, tying these ideas back to
Epstein, I found an article recently in
the Dutch news that was talking about a
painting Jeffrey Epstein had ordered.
That was a painting of I'm pretty sure
it was the
the slaughtering of the babies in the
Bible times like with Pharaoh. I was
Pharaoh, I'm pretty sure. Or was Herod?
One of those two. The original painter
supposedly had painted it as a warning
like this should never happen again.
But then he just said, I want a copy of
that and put it in my house. Why would
he want that put in his house?
>> That's what I'm saying. It's like it's
like why would you even want to subject
yourself to the imagery of this
darkness? Mhm. Like like just to have
something like that in your house and
people walk in. Like what are you going
to say? Oh, nice picture. Yeah. Like
what's wrong with you if you're if
you're doing this? You know, we're
talking about human beings here. We're
talking about like, you know, God's
creation, even if it is animals.
Honestly,
it's so sad to me how far humanity has
actually
uh fallen. I think this is probably one
of the most disturbing things I've yet
seen and I'm just like
and you know, and I think the reason why
you're bringing this up and why you
prefer why you wanted to talk about this
today is because
you want to show like
following these people is no joke. Like
this is no joke. These people are
seriously you know, like and and we
don't know if all these people you
showed today were friends with Epstein
or unless we find that they're they
were, but you know, we don't know if
they were specifically involved with the
baby
um
um eating that or slaughtering,
whatever. It's found in Epstein files.
We don't know that, but at the same time
Epstein was disturbing, these people are
highly disturbing and you can see that
if these people are that satanic and
that dark, but we want to be Christians,
become more like Christ, look at this.
Don't look at that stuff. And I think
that's why you wanted to talk about
this, right? To show like this is what's
out there and and and you will be be
dragged into the mud if you keep looking
at these people. I'm telling you that
these artists that that mainstream
people think, oh, it's just a song or
oh, they're just weird.
These are extremely disturbing things
and we know that music affects us,
right?
>> Yeah. We know that all of these these
influences that we see, taste, touch,
hear are going to influence us. So, I
think, guys, it is time to put this
worldly music down. Don't support this.
Talked about Aleister Crowley a lot on
this show. His he was most famously
quoted for do as thou wilt is the whole
of the law and that's basically the
opposite of the Ten Commandments. It's
simply just like whatever you want to
do. If you want to eat babies, you can
do that. And this is someone that the
music industry loves. That's why the
Beatles put him on their cover. So, you
have Aleister Crowley and he also lived
in a cult commune. It was called the
Abbey uh where he practiced dark magic
and so this is why some people connect
the Beatles album Abbey Road to Aleister
Crowley because, you know, they were
already influenced by the Beatles and so
they say, oh, he they named him after
the album after Aleister Crowley. Is
that what they did or not? I don't know,
but that's the connection people make.
This interview took place when Kanye
West was on his um sort of religious
direction and was becoming Christian and
David Letterman asked him a really
interesting question about the type of
music that he played in his Sunday
service. Listen to this. Uh yesterday, I
feel lucky to have been invited to a
performance of your work and of the your
orchestration in a sound studio in in
Burbank, California. It was so uh moving
and inspirational
that I said to you, I wish my family had
been here for this because there's no
way I'm going to be able to explain to
them what a lovely hour this was. What
What can you tell us about this? It's
the You call it the Sunday service?
Yeah, I mean, we we were really light on
even giving it a name. It's just an idea
that we had to
open up
our hearts and make music that we felt
was as pure and as positive as possible
and just do it for an hour every Sunday
and have something where people can come
together and just feel good with their
family. About I heard that that certain
John Lennon or Bob Marley songs that can
move sand on a plate, that frequencies
can do that. So, I've been a so-called
professional musician
you know, for 15, 20 years and never
thought about that till we do our
service in a circle.
And I removed the program drums
programming, like what I talked about,
the high hats.
The 808 that usually hits inside of the
lowest chakra, which is your sex chakra.
And then you have all the information
that one of God's favorite angels that
was in charge of music came down and
started putting messages in. You know,
the devil is also the angel of music and
that his rib cage is shaped like a harp.
So, that 808 that a lot of our music is
And then they put up I'm going to I'm
going to kill you. And that's that
frequency that's rolling. And then, oh,
here, pop this medication while you pop
some Molly's, pop some And that is the
standard culture right now of music.
That is what's controlling it, this this
pill nightlife.
I
>> [gasps]
>> I just think it's
fascinating what he's saying here. I
mean, if anybody knows about music, it's
this guy.
And what he's really talking about how
that certain types of music, like he
wasn't really necessarily even beginning
the the illustration that he was giving
here with the words. He was saying that
the beats and things like that is what
really opens you up and then when
they're saying these words and preaching
into your into your subconscious, you
know, you're basically doing what
they're telling you to do, programming.
That's why he removed the programming
drums. Yeah, maybe we can drop in that
uh clip here of Rob Long, who was one of
Diddy's producers, but do you remember
what he said? My my experience with it
is that it's it's
is highly demonic and there's doors that
are opening when you participate
and
if you're going to do it on a high
level, put it this way, you're going to
have to tap into something else.
Nobody's doing it on a high level
and they're in perfect communion with
God. It just doesn't happen.
That's a strong statement.
It don't happen.
Because in order to do it on a high
level
and to reach the masses with
the message of hip hop and R&B
it's going to have to go beyond the
natural plane. It's going to have to go
into something supernatural.
I tapped into it, so I I know I know
what it is.
>> you mean by you tapped? I tapped into
it. I I I would There would be certain
um times when I'm working
that my natural ability
I couldn't come up with certain beat
like it just didn't flow. But once I,
you know, got into some weed or
got into something
I had to alter my mind. Now I can hear
Now I can hear
Now those beats would just come like
like naturally. It would just flow. So
you got to the phone before me ask you a
question. Do you think
that the music some of the music that
you hear at a high level
is influenced
by other sources? 110%
All of it. There isn't you There's
certain There's gatekeeping. You can't
get past a certain level without going
through gates.
You can't get past it. So I want to
bring this up.
Baal, we've talked about this
in the music industry. I mean, he he is
someone that has not gone away back in
Elijah's day. He's kind of transformed
and and often he's spoken about in the
music industry.
So Baal is a Canaanite god.
>> Yeah. Way back when and what they were
attributing to Baal was basically saying
that he created the universe. He's the
one that was controlling the rain so
that it would grow the crops. He was the
known as the prosperity. It was the
reason why we do well in life is because
of Baal and he has this enemy called
Mot. Yeah. They battle together. Baal
gets killed, dies, and is resurrected
and comes back and becomes the savior of
the of the world. This is kind of their
folklore. Well, Baal was also worshipped
by the Babylonians. It's highly
recognized today as a Babylonian god.
Yes.
>> And then Babylon in the Bible is
literally it was historically it's it's
it was a place. It was a city
um
in the Bible it's mentioned in the Old
Testament and the New Testament it's
actually I would say
it's symbolically of the Antichrist
power Yes. And he's changed names and
similar different gods have popped up
throughout different cultures like
Moloch, right?
>> But the interesting thing that I want to
bring up to up to you today isn't
necessarily just the tie into the music
industry, but
they were sacrificing their babies to
Baal. Yeah. That's what he was known for
was sacrificing the babies. Okay? Are
you going to talk about Epstein and
Baal? They've had a lot of things that
are tied back into the Baal worship.
Didn't Shawn say that? Shawn's one of
our co-workers here and he mentioned
that there's been many YouTubers who've
gone to the island and they saw that
they Yeah, they tried to get on the
island.
So people on the internet are connecting
the dots that Jeffrey Epstein's temple
looks exactly like a place called Hamam
Yalbuga. Now we go to Hamam Yalbuga's
Wikipedia page. It says
Yalbuga is a Mamluk era public bath in
Aleppo, Syria. It was built in 1491.
So this is a place that offers massages.
You can go to a sauna here. And uh the
connection that strikes out to me right
away is massages is how Jeffrey Epstein
groomed his young 14 to 16-year-old
victims. He had a private mansion over
there in Palm Beach and what he would do
is he would pay recruiters to go out and
find women and say, "Hey, there's this
rich guy in Palm Beach. He'll give you
$200 if you go in and give him a
massage. Only catch is you got to do it
in your underwear."
So this is how he would invite girls
into his mansion. They'd give him the
massage and of course Epstein would
offer more money for a little bit more
than just a massage. And this is how he
kind of figured out what he could get
away with.
Um
the guy is super into massages himself.
It's just an interesting connection.
All right. So we go on the Wikipedia
page and we click Mamluk era. What is
that? On its Wikipedia page we see
Mamluk is Arabic meaning property.
Um it's an Arabic designation for
slaves. The term is most commonly used
to refer to non-Muslim slave soldiers
and Muslim ruler rulers of slave origin.
So what is Jeffrey Epstein guilty of?
He's guilty of sex trafficking,
basically slaves. And what is the
architecture that he styles his temple
off of but Mamluk architecture, which is
indicative to slave culture?
All right. So another interesting
connection with the Hamam Yalbuga is
right here on the Wikipedia page. It
says, "It is located next to the
entrance of the Citadel of Aleppo on the
banks of the Quwaiq River."
So what is the Citadel of Aleppo? So
according to Wikipedia, the Citadel of
Aleppo is considered to be one of the
oldest and largest castles in the world.
So then we scroll down to the history
section of the Citadel of Aleppo and it
says the recently discovered temple of
the ancient storm god Hadad dates use of
the hill to the middle of the third
millennium BC.
So who is Hadad?
Go to Hadad's Wikipedia page. I kid you
not. I can't make this up. Hadad is
another name for Baal.
It says Hadad was also called Pidar,
Rapu, or Baalsiphon, or simply referred
to as Baal.
Um I think it's worth noting that Baal
is also used as the title for other gods
as well, but still the bull was the
symbolic animal of Hadad, which also
dates to which also relates to Moloch.
Well, the common conspiracy here that we
hear all the time is that these
billionaires they are Baal worshipers,
Moloch worshipers, and Satanists. So how
does all of this tie into the evidence
that we are now seeing coming from
Epstein's Island?
All right. So let's So look at the
side-by-side pictures of Epstein's
temple and the bathhouse over in Aleppo.
Look at the the similarities. It's it's
unbelievable. Uh we can say at the very
least they are resembling the same
architecture and the architecture is in
fact the Mamluks. So who are the
Mamluks? The Mamluks were a class of
people mostly of Turkic or Caucasian
ethnicity and the second period saw the
rise of Borji Circassian dynasty, which
ruled from 1382 to 1517 AD. The
Circassian Mamluks were the white slaves
that were taken from the northern
Caucasus Mountains and traded in slave
markets. They were captured in their
early childhood, usually around 13 years
of age, by the sultans who raised them
in special military camps to become
soldiers for the ruling class.
So let's look at this quote from
Voltaire what he has to say about the
Circassians. The Circassians are poor
and their daughters are beautiful and
indeed it is them they chiefly trade.
And of all those who are wealthy enough
to purchase and maintain such precious
merchandise, these maidens are very
honorably and virtually instructed how
to fondle and caress men and how to
heighten by the most voluptuous
artifices the pleasures of their
disdainful masters for whom they are
designed.
So this architectural decision was also
pushed by the Sufis or Islamic mystics.
And what's so fascinating is these
people they were obsessed with the sun
and what do we find also on Jeffrey
Epstein's Island but a giant occult
painting of the sun?
So yeah, right here we see an image of
the sun
on Jeffrey Epstein's Island, Little
Saint James. This is drone footage taken
by a YouTuber named Rusty Shackelford
who's done great work. He actually
purchased a drone, went out to the
Virgin Islands himself, and got a lot of
amazing video
of this island.
So what is the meaning then behind
Epstein's temple? Epstein's temple was
an ode to the Mamluk era of when
captured children were taken as slaves
to do the bidding of the elite class.
Young boys were taken and groomed to
later become soldiers while young girls
were taken and groomed to later become
personal concubines of their masters.
And a lot of people There's a There's a
a bar on the outside of it to lock
whoever is inside of there in. You don't
normally put a lock on the outside. So
there is an interview that was done with
a survivor of child sex trafficking done
with Andrew Gold who has a podcast
called What is it? It's Hurt Hurtic's
podcast.
>> podcast.
And
she
in this interview claims that she was
sold to the elites Mhm. for human
trafficking and it's really interesting
though when you hear very similar
stories from people like this and you
compare them to other stories
>> Yep. like what's happening with the as
far as what we know with the Epstein
files and
other ones that have come out from, you
know,
elites or industry people as well. What
do you think about that? It's It's
fascinating when you see a lot of
similar details come out
>> that are similar to each other. When I
was nine and there was a ritual that was
set up to please one of the people that
was coming um to Belgium for the
Bilderberg meeting and so for this
American billionaire they they staged
a satanic ritual.
And that had the elements of Satanism
with everybody wearing black robes and
you know, and hoods.
And um it was a
>> [sighs]
>> It took place in um
below a cathedral in the basement of a
cathedral.
Uh it seemed
um
that was sort of the reverse of what was
happening upstairs and so there there
wasn't a very old altar, a black altar,
and there was um a pentagram and I don't
know. There There were all the elements
were there.
And um
>> [snorts]
>> two children were off given to this
billionaire.
But we're talking about children here
and she had to witness one of the most
crazy things that I've ever seen ever
heard in my entire life. Yeah. Yeah, and
so you were saying that in this clip
they they were in kind of like almost
like a cathedral thing. They had
black robes on them like a full on
satanic sacrifice. Okay. So she mentions
this about being in the bottom of the
church because it's like opposite of
what you know a cathedral is obviously
Roman Catholicism. I want to mention
because you mentioned earlier Bale in
the in the music industry. We have a
video that we should put in the
description about Bale in the music
industry and maybe we can put a clip in
here for that. Anyway, getting back to
this, he is the god of fertility, the
weather, rain especially. Rain Man is
one of his names. Wind, lightning,
seasons, war, and soldiers. What about
prosperity?
Yes. So that is huge.
It's not listed in here. I got some of
these names from exposing
the music industry
film which oh please go and watch that.
The whole thing's good. So as it
pertains to using the name Rain Man,
this is something or referring to rain.
It would be given
as an individual's name. You could say I
am Rain Man no matter what gender you
are
to try to
pay homage
to Bale so that he will bless your life
with fame, money, prosperity. Yeah, it's
the same as all these people we we've
talked about this a lot but you know
Satan offered Jesus all the kingdoms of
the world. He's the god of this world.
He can give you all these riches and
everything but these are all temporal
things. Store not your treasures here on
earth but store your treasures in heaven
because you you can't take any of it
with you. It's all going to burn one
day. Right. And so but these people who
have taken that offer, a lot of
celebrities whether they're
basketball players, musicians, whatever,
you'll see them throw those signs up
with their hands, the 666, the horns and
they'll just sit there and flash them
back to back. You're like, why are they
doing that? I've literally seen like
LeBron or somebody
he's not even looking at the camera. The
camera's he's just looking kind of up
and
just like flashing and he's just like,
what is he doing? But he's just giving
allegiance just like we would be praying
like God help me help me do this thing,
you know, speak through me. The more
times that you can actually pay homage
through symbols, through
whatever you do and say, the more it's
said that you are going to be blessed
with fame and fortune.
You call on Rain Man or rain
meaning that someone in reference to
someone who offers abundant blessings
from above, someone who likes to make it
rain meaning
here's how we get into the symbolism
here.
Um, I'm reading from that area throwing
money on strippers or towards strippers
usually carrying a lot of cash in his
hand ready to throw.
Someone who can give you any woman or
man you desire.
Someone who can make you rich or famous.
The Rain Man symbolism can be shown in
several ways but mainly in pop and hip
hop music it is shown by throwing money
or having money appear to be coming down
from above.
So Rain Man is
as we're connecting the dots Baphomet or
the devil.
>> [music]
[music]
[singing]
>> We look at those videos and from outside
it doesn't seem like there is something
evil about it. But in the context we
know like yeah that this is bad. But at
the same time it's like
you can say wow like this is crazy but
the music has nothing to do with it. But
at the same time it's like what do you
want to
do you not want to
uh, participate you can say participate
with the evil but you still step into
the territory of Satan. Like might as
well not just even step in that. So
maybe before you can say, oh I didn't
know so I listened to this music but now
since you see that all of this is
connected and it's not just about the
music, maybe it's time to rethink the
music that we're listening and the
things that we're watching and not just
these couple songs mentioned here but
there is more that
also lead in that direction. I want to
share this article. We've shared it a
couple times on this channel but if
you're new to the channel you probably
haven't seen this but Taylor Swift in
Time magazine she was commenting on the
people that she
that follow her music and listen to her
stuff. Swift is happy to minister to
them. They're discovering the music that
tells them how they're going to live
their lives and how they should feel and
how it's acceptable to feel, Swift says.
I think that that's kind of exciting. So
here she's ministering to her fans and
then recognizing that her music tells
them how they should live their life.
That's so crazy.
>> I thought that was crazy. Do you
recognize this lady?
This is Salt-N-Pepa,
one of them. I don't remember which one
but this was a music group that was
popular when we were kids and
they had some pretty
like
racy content
but she has really gotten back to the
Bible and listen to the advice that she
gives. I think it's great advice.
Hey y'all, so the cat's out the bag.
I've been studying this type of thing
for years but you can't really talk
about it cuz people will think that
you're crazy. So now we know Satanists
and Luciferians run the world. Second
Corinthians it describes that Satan is
the god of this world. They own the
government, politics, Democrats and
Republicans, the court system, the
education system, the banks, the Federal
Reserve, real estate, farms,
Hollywood, what we watch, music, what we
listen to, media, what we believe,
sports, big pharma, everything. People
will laugh at that but when it comes to
their god, they're on their job. They
pray to their god, they worship him,
they murder, assault children, make
blood sacrifices. They are very
dedicated to making sure their god is
pleased with them. We can stop feeding
the beast with our dollars. When things
are exposed, we can stop giving them our
money. Even this information we've been
exposed to, I think it's designed to see
what we will do. This information can
make us feel helpless and depressed and
even more complacent giving them even
more control to usher in their new world
order, their one world government, one
currency, one world dictatorship where
we have no rights at all. But in the
revelation, yes, we are being led to a
choice, right? It talks about the mark
of the beast in Revelation 13:16
through 17. You can read it for yourself
but
that's basically where this is all
headed and it's unfolding right in front
of us. There'll be a time that we won't
be able to buy or sell unless we take
the mark. Can you imagine one world
government,
one religion,
one currency,
total dictatorship, total control. Let's
do what we can. Um, spread information
and God bless you guys.
You know, I I really truly believe that
we are coming to a a point in history
where it's like it's time to make a
stand. And if you've never ever really
considered or thought about a
relationship with Jesus or you don't
even know where to start. Um, honestly
we want to inspire you because as this
stuff is coming out, trust me, it's
almost like the world is is backing up
and showing how evil and dark it is
behind the scenes because prophetically
speaking
Satan is going to try and counterfeit
the coming of Jesus. And so for him to
show you how evil this world is, there
is a calculated systematic plan to make
you so disgusted with this world that
you're just like, give me a savior. I
need a savior. And then all of a sudden
he'll go, I'll save you. But here's the
key difference.
The difference between Jesus and a false
Christ is going to come down to, does it
speak according to the law and to the
testimonies?
Does it speak the same as the Bible? If
it's if it's blending Babylonian or
other ideas and stuff that's not
supportive of the Bible, you pretty much
know if he's walking around on this
planet, we know that's not Jesus because
Jesus will not set his feet on this
planet. I think it'll even I think it'll
even be that much more difficult because
at the end of the day, Satan if he's
going to imitate Christ, he's not going
to be like, you know what? Everybody
just
you know, flagrantly break all the laws
and and all that kind of stuff. I think
he's going to come on the scene
and he's going to promote
Christianity.
Promote you know,
most of the 10 Commandments. Promote
you know,
godly living so to speak.
But there's going to be a couple things
that are off. Yeah.
It's going to look close. Yeah. It'll be
close, but it won't be the right thing.
It won't be pure. It'll be mixed with a
drop of poison. That's why Matthew 7
says, you know, many of us will say,
"Lord, Lord, have we not prophesied in
your name? Have we not like cast out
demons in your name? Have we not done
all these wonderful things in your
name?" He will say, "I do not know you."
I don't know you, you practitioners of
lawlessness. You practice lawlessness.
What is What is the What is the
definition or Well, definition of sin is
the breaking of God's 10 Commandments.
That's right.
>> So, and also elsewhere in the Bible cuz
he said if you break one of these,
you've broken all of them. You have to
keep all of them. And not because we're
some like legalistic kind of people,
it's because
it's because Jesus says if you love me,
keep my Commandments. It's the same
reason that I'm faithful to my husband
cuz I love my husband. I'm not going to
go out, you know, cheating on him and
sleeping with somebody else. It's
because I love my husband and I'm
faithful to him.
And it's not a burden. It is It is a
joyful thing to keep the marriage vows
or the marriage Commandments or laws.
It's the same with God.
>> You know, there's a a very close link in
Matthew 7 when he says, "And then I will
declare to them, I never knew you."
So, knowing God, a relationship with God
Yeah. becomes very dependent on what he
says next, you who practice lawlessness.
So, you can't Jesus is essentially
saying, "You can't really have a
relationship with me. You don't really
know me if you're not doing the things
that I've asked you to do. If you're
going against my word, if you're
practicing lawlessness, if you're a
commandment-breaking person, then
there's no way we even have a
relationship and I can't I can't even
know you because
we're not on the same page." And it's so
interesting when you mentioned about
ball,
he's not real, like he's fake.
>> Right.
>> But behind it, we know that it's Satan.
And it's interesting how people worship
Bale, but basically it's Satan. And then
in the end of the time, like in the end
of the day, it will be about worship.
There is also worshipping God.
And that's by doing his will, obviously.
That's right. That's right. He is my
all. Surrender all to him. And you know,
Jesus is coming back soon. Seriously, if
you just can
see the signs all over, but while the
door of mercy is still open, we want to
encourage each and every one of you
guys.
Um, you know, if you have questions,
reach out. We will respond. And uh, if
you want to dig deeper, you know, you
want to look more into this, please let
us know. We will We will point you in a
direction to try to give you those
answers. We got a free online Bible
school where you could just study the
Bible for yourself, including about, you
know, who's the Antichrist and what's
going to happen in the future, American
Bible prophecy. And like you said, Great
Controversy is a free book that uh, is
basically just full of history and also
Bible prophecy. So. And honestly, it can
start as simply as just going, "God, I
don't know you. Show me who you are."
That's right. [music]
If you're still listening to worldly
music, brothers and sisters, I'm telling
you it will change your life. [music]
So, we pray that
time is short. Get your relationship
right with Jesus when you can. And uh,
he's coming back soon. We want to be
ready to see him coming. So, thanks for
watching. As always, keep us in your
prayers.
God bless. So, as you've noticed, we're
back, but we're not back like you
thought we might have been back. This
isn't LED Live in a regular episode like
we used to. It's one here and there.
Yeah. So, make sure you subscribe. We
don't want you to miss anything that
we're going to put out. We are working
on some big projects, some documentaries
that you'd be interested in. The next
documentary we're working on is Should
we tell them what it's about?
>> Nah, let's keep it a secret. But you can
check Patreon if you want to know that
cuz Daryl tell you. It is pretty cool.
>> Yeah, it's epic. [laughter] And it's a
little different than things that we've
done in the past. So, I will say that
much. Yeah. But if you want to know
what's being leaked out, you got to get
on Patreon and you can find all the
extra tidbits there.
>> [music]
[music]